this is always such a hard thing to do
but today I'm saying goodbye Abby
Huntsman is leaving the view the 33 year
old TV personality who joined the panel
in September 2018 made the announcement
at the top of Monday's show explaining
the special reason behind her decision
I was asked months ago with my dad who's
running for governor your time to come
help run the campaign I know it's not
the right time and there's no one I
believe in more than my own dad right
now to run for politics and but there's
good news the mother of three said she's
leaving the door open for a possible
return after her dad's campaign and it's
easy to see why
Abby clearly loves her job her fellow
panelists and the crew I love all of you
here I do I just want to give a big
THANK YOU to you guys first and foremost
cuz you guys are friends one a thing but
thank you for welcomed me into your
homes and for believing in me as well
and I just I'm so thankful for this
opportunity and I'm also very excited
about the next chapter and that love is
more than mutual I'm heartbroken you're
leaving but I think I can understand
better than anybody how important it is
to go support your dad is one of the
nicest and easiest people I've ever
worked with
I really value your friendship so
clearly values don't just dump us I'm so
lucky to have this job but we're all
human beings too et was with Abby in
September right before she started the
current season of the view she was
incredibly candid about balancing her
roles as a mom and TV personality I
think there's so many people that watch
the show that are at home that are just
trying to get through each day and even
though it looks like we have everything
put together when we're on television
and I go home and deal with the same
poopy diapers and a little sleep and you
know all that stuff and so I hope to
just every day provides that realness
because we don't get that enough from
people I feel like we're living in this
world where again everything is that it
at everything looks perfect
and that's not the reality it's not for
now the view is not naming a permanent
replacement for a bee
[Music]